and Indiana school superintendent says
she broke the law because she was
unwilling to turn her back on a student
in need
Casey Smither and used her own insurance
to pay for a 15 year old boys doctor
visit and medication she could have
faced jail time for insurance and
identity fraud but will enter a
diversion program instead the school
district is standing behind her
Smith Smitherman explained to Dean
Reynolds the lessons she learned about
doing the wrong thing for the right
reasons Casey Smitherman the
superintendent of the Elwood Indiana
Community Schools had never been
arrested and booked before this month
that is I was scared because I'm a rule
follower and I had never done something
like that something like taking a 15
year old student with a bad sore throat
but no health insurance to a medical
clinic passing him off as her son then
she got a prescription in her son's name
for him and used her own coverage to pay
for it I wish that I could redo it and
do it differently but at the time I was
worried about him and thinking about his
health care soon after she told the
police what she'd done and turned
herself in she was charged with
insurance fraud identity deception and
official misconduct
Rodney Cummings is the local prosecutor
probably not the best example to set for
young people to assume other identities
and and make false statements what led
you to tell the police what you had done
he shared the story and with friends
with a teacher I believe and so I knew
it was important that I just tell the
truth and so I called the police and
told the truth
did it weigh on your conscience yes
completely I'm not suggesting what I did
was right but trying to find ways to
help all of our kids is so important in
this school district where 78% of the
kids qualify for free or reduced lunches
groups of teachers have identified
struggling students to help with food
clothing and mentoring casey says it's a
teacher thing overwhelmingly the calls
that I've received in the last day have
been from other school teachers and I've
heard from Seattle to New Jersey and
it's been I recognize this I've felt
that way myself I've helped kids myself
and so it's apply educators across our
country deal with under an agreement
with the prosecutor the charges will be
dropped if she gets through the next
year without another arrest Casey says
she can definitely do that
for CBS this morning Dean Reynolds
Elwood Indiana look at the sign behind
her on the dust it says you can never
have too much happy we all know it's not
the right thing to do but I think I can
understand why she did what she did when
she felt so strongly about it
and why she's sharing it you know we
need to fix our priorities exactly about
what's important when they're kids who
don't have insurance that can't get the
proper medical care when they're sick
yeah